صباح الأربعاء في كابول ونحن
ذاهبون إلى مدرسة البنات من خلال هذه
الستائر البلاستيكية وأعين المتطفلين الماضية ،
نعم ، أصبح استوديو الأزياء هذا
مرفقًا تعليميًا بديلاً منذ أن
منعت طالبان الفتيات من الالتحاق
بالمدارس الثانوية الحكومية
أرادت نجمة الروك البالغة من العمر سبعة عشر عامًا أن
تكون  الدكتورة الآن تتعلم كيف تصبح
خياطة
نشعر بالسوء الشديد فهي تخبرنا أن
الفتيات غير قادرات على الذهاب إلى المدرسة
والبقاء في المنزل دون القيام بأي شيء ونأمل أن
يغير هذا حياتنا حتى نتمكن من
تحقيق الاكتفاء الذاتي والحصول على مهنة تعلم
كسب المال  لإعالة أنفسنا
وعائلاتنا ،
أرادت نداء أن تكون لاعب كرة
قدم محترف ، فأنت تبلغ من العمر 17 عامًا ولم تعرف أبدًا
حكومة طالبان ،
هل تخيلت يومًا
أن هذا سيحدث لك أنك
ستمنع من الذهاب إلى المدرسة
[موسيقى]
لا أبدًا.  لقد بذلنا قصارى جهدنا من أجل
مستقبلنا ، لكنه مستقبل مظلم الآن
لأننا بعيدين عن مدارسنا
بدأت ناجينا حفيزي
نشاط الأزياء هذا مع أخواتها منذ أربع سنوات
اليوم.  إنها تدير المقاومة
عندما أغلق الطالبان الباب في
وجوههم ، فتحت بابها أمام فتيات المدارس الثانوية
بهدف
تدريبهن بشكل كاف على كسب لقمة العيش وإعالة
أنفسهن في غضون 6 إلى 12 شهرًا ، وهي
تفعل هذا لـ 120 فتاة وامرأة في
ثلاثة مواقع.
أنت تساعدهم ولكنهم جميعًا يريدون أن
يكونوا أطباء أو رياضيين أو تعرف
محترفين يريدون
الالتحاق بالجامعة ، ما هو شعورك حيال اضطرارهم إلى العمل في التطريز أو الخياطة.
الأحلام جيدة جدًا ، الأمر مختلف
عندما يجبرون على القيام بشيء
آخر وهذا شعور سيء لأن معظم
هؤلاء الفتيات يرغبن في الذهاب إلى الجامعة
لتصبح طبيبة ومعلمة ومهندسة ،
إنه أمر صعب للغاية بالنسبة لهن وأنا أعلم
أنهم لا يستطيعون ذلك.  القيام بأي عمل آخر حتى
يتمكنوا على الأقل من تعلم مهنة الخياطة من
أجل مستقبلهم
للسجل ،
أخبرني نائب زعيم طالبان القوي سراج الدين حقاني
تلك الفتاة.  ستفتح المدارس الثانوية العامة
مرة أخرى قريبًا ، وهذا بالطبع
يحق للمرأة العمل ضمن
الإطار الإسلامي ،
لكن منذ 26 عامًا ، أجريت نفس
المحادثات حول نفس القضايا عندما
كانت طالبان هي المسؤولة في البداية ،
يريد الكثير من الناس معرفة ماذا
ستفعلون بشأن قضية المرأة ، ماذا عن
تعليم النساء ، تعليم الفتيات ، النساء
الأرامل العاملات اللائي ليس لديهن طريقة أخرى
لإعالة أنفسهن ،
أعلم أنه بشكل خاص في وسائل الإعلام الغربية ،
إنها دعاية ضد
حقيقة أننا ضد تعليم المرأة
وهو ليس كذلك  صحيح ، هذا ليس صحيحًا
لكن الفتيات لا يمكنهن الذهاب إلى المدرسة ، لقد ذهبنا
إلى المدارس هنا التي تم إغلاقها جميعًا ،
لقد
أخبرناهم للتو أنه في الوقت الحالي
لا يجب عليهم القدوم إلى المكتب في المدرسة ،
لذا حتى يحين الوقت الذي يمكننا فيه
القدوم  بالخروج بنوع من الحل ،
حتى الأصغر سناً يفهم شيئًا ما
ليس صحيحًا ،
تشكو عزيزة من اضطرارها
للبقاء في المنزل طوال اليوم ،
فنحن نقوم فقط بالأعمال المنزلية لتنظيف خبز
الخبز وكنس العوامة  أو
تقول إنني أحب عملي ، إنه من حقي أن
أعمل وأحتاج إلى العمل لأنني تلقيت التعليم
في هذا البلد وأنفقت الحكومة
الكثير علي
وعلى عائلتي وأريد أن أعبر
عن نفسي
لمجتمعي شجاع ثم شجاع
الآن فقط  بعد أكثر من عقدين من
التقدم لزوجاتهم
، بناتهم وأسرهم دخل الكثير من
الرجال الأفغان
يدعمهم ، يخبرنا أحمد أنه لا يوجد حتى واحد بالمائة من
الشعب الأفغاني ضد عمل النساء ،
فنحن لا نريد أن يكبر شعبنا كما
لو أننا  نحن في غابة ، نريد أن يكون لدى الناس
معرفة ثقافية ، نحتاج إلى الطعام
ونعمل
مرة أخرى في استوديو التصميم ، هذه الفصول
ليست مفتوحة فقط لطلاب المدارس
الثانوية ولكن للنساء الأكبر سنًا اللائي أصبحن
فجأة عاطلين عن العمل مثل ربيعة البالغة من العمر 30
عامًا وهي معلمة
نشعر بالاختناق تقول لماذا لا يمكننا
في بلدنا أن نعيش مكاننا
بحرية ونتحرك بحرية أينما ذهبنا
مهما كان العمل الذي نقوم به يضعون حواجز في
طريقنا لا يمكننا الوصول إلى أهدافنا في الحياة
نخشى دائمًا ما إذا كان  قبل
الحكومة الفاسدة أو نظام إمارة طالبان
تأتي ربيعة إلى هنا لإعادة التدريب ومثل
العديد من الأمهات والزوجات
ليحظوا بنوع من الحياة الاجتماعية مثل نور جان
التي أرادت ابنتها ندى أن تصبح
لاعبة كرة قدم
عندما أشعر بالاستياء حقًا ، أخبرتني
زوجي.  يقول يجب أن آتي إلى هنا حتى
أتمكن على الأقل من مقابلة الآخرين ،
زوجي لطيف للغاية ،
نحن جميعًا أخوات هنا
كريستيانا مانبور سي إن إن كابول أفغانستان